i'm charles payne i'm martha mccallum
i'm greg jarrett and this is the fox
news rundown
friday december 3rd 2021 i'm lisa brady
testing masking and vaccination will it
be enough again to fight kobit's latest
variant or future variants we have to
learn how to
deal with this and
i think that's what you will see more
people begin to do we speak with
tennessee senator marsha blackburn i'm
chris foster a long era of labor pieces
over in major league baseball for now
there are no games to play anyway if we
get to super bowl sunday and they're
still in nowhere's land like they are
now that's a big problem and i'm david
marcus
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
with health officials on the lookout for
kobit's new variant didn't take long for
the first u.s cases to surface
california then minnesota then colorado
all three of those cases fully
vaccinated people with only mild
symptoms at least two had traveled
recently in south africa but the
minnesota resident tested positive after
returning from an anime convention in
new york city and local reports of cases
there began to emerge late thursday we
knew there'd be cases
of this
of omicron here in the united states and
it's here
but we have the best tools the best
vaccines in the world the best medicine
and the best scientists in the world
after meetings at the national
institutes of health on thursday
president biden offering an updated plan
to fight covet heading into the winter
testing is a big part of it with tighter
restrictions on all air travelers
entering the u.s all inbound
international travelers must test within
one day of departure
regardless of their vaccination status
or nationality he says at home kova
tests will be covered by insurance
beginning next month and masks on public
transportation including planes will now
be required at least until mid-march
instead of ending next month as planned
but he's not imposing any new mandates
or lockdowns we have to learn how to
live and to deal with this tennessee
republican senator marsha blackburn we
don't need to go into lockdowns we don't
need to shut down our economy
people need to talk to their physician
if they are a candidate to receive a
vaccine and some people are not you know
because of medical
issues because of certain health or
chronic conditions they have or maybe a
religious exemption but
we have to learn how to
deal with this and
i think that's what you will see more
people begin to do i know part of the
president's focus is a bigger emphasis
on testing both at home
and for travelers coming to the u.s
health officials do keep saying though
vaccines are really the best defense
is there a way to get more people
vaccinated aside from federal mandates
which are still oh this is important and
i'm one of those i am not anti-backs i
mean a lot of vaccines have done
much good work i'm one of those i get a
flu shot every year not everybody yeah a
flu shot doesn't work with them so this
is something that should be handled by
the individual not by federal mandate
and
what we do know is testing can be
effective we know that there are some
antivirals and therapies that are coming
into the marketplace
those should be a consideration there as
we learn how to manage and handle
this virus
in just a few weeks the us is expected
to hit its debt limit again i know
senate republican leader mitch mcconnell
has said democrats should deal with that
on their own and then democrats turn
around and say well that's irresponsible
of republicans
where does that debate go from here
about the debt limit with the debt limit
we have to realize that the democrats
have created this problem they've been
unable to organize themselves this year
that's why the national defense
authorization act is not completed it's
why they are having such issues with a
continuing resolution and biden's
buildback broke agenda
they are not successful in pulling
together a timeline
for addressing the issues that are in
front of them
and in essence they are ineffective when
it comes to
leading our country because right now
they control the house the senate and
the white house
this week on capitol hill
former facebook employee turned
whistleblower francis haugen was back
urging lawmakers not to get stuck at an
impasse on changes to reining in
social media companies
she's urging limits on liability
protections for the companies she's also
cautioning congress about
how to do that though are you optimistic
especially given
the current you know political climate
in washington um are you optimistic you
can find that balance and actually get
something done on that issue
you know we don't take policy advice
from her by any means and
online privacy and data security
legislation section 230 reforms are
issues that i have worked on going back
to my time in the house
and currently senator blumenthal and i
lead the consumer protection data
security subcommittee at the commerce
committee
last congress we worked together when i
led
the technology task force for the senate
judiciary committee
and
we are hard at work on privacy
children's privacy data security and
section 230 reforms and that legislation
will be coming forward soon
can you give us any
sort of overview of what it will look
like
it's many of the things i've talked
about for years having one set of
privacy rules for the entire internet
ecosystem one regulator the federal
trade commission
also being able for individuals the
individual user to protect what i call
their virtual you
which is you and your presence online
by having to opt in and give explicit
consent if you want to have your
information shared and of course the
ability to opt out of a platform
remembering data mining or utilizing in
any way your search history
i know something else you've been very
outspoken about is
china
and the white house keeps saying it's
trying to manage competition between the
us and china but prevent competition
from veering into conflict is it
possible to do that and still stand up
to beijing
this administration would be well served
to
get it in their mind
china is not a competitor they are not a
friend they are not a frenemy they are
an adversary and this administration is
going to have to admit that and realize
that
and i know president biden felt like he
could talk to his old friend xi jinping
and could handle some of these issues
i bet what he is going to have to
realize and admit
is xi jinping
is
an authoritarian
and is
intent on pushing china as the global
leader removing
the us as the world's superpower and
supplanting our place
what would you like to see
the u.s doing differently right now when
it comes to china
the us and this administration is going
to have to be more strident with china
when it comes to dealing with sanctions
and holding china to account for their
human rights violations what is taking
place there in xinjiang province uh the
genocide that's being carried out
against the weakers
the atrocities they've carried out
against the tibetans the mongolians the
way they have bullied hong kong the way
they are bullying taiwan the u.s needs
to say no we're not going to put up with
this we know what you are doing and we
are not going to allow it
the u.s also needs to be paying close
attention to how china
is trying to utilize the belton road
initiative
to extend their economic reach and also
their debt diplomacy
i know that europe european countries
the eu let's say and the u.s
are
coming up with investments that are
supposed to help counter that chinese
belt and road initiative which is really
the chinese effort to connect asia with
europe and africa
um as you mentioned you know expanding
their their economic reach do you think
those coordinated efforts on the part of
european countries in the u.s will be
enough to counter that or will even make
a dent
i do think that they are significant and
they are important and let's start with
realizing that our enemies need to know
that they are our enemy and our allies
need to know that they are our ally and
that we will stand with them and a part
of this
defense against china is true economic
participation and partnership
and as you look at supply chains that
need to come out of china whether it's
semiconductor chips or
our microprocessors or pharmaceuticals
or telecommunications
equipment
these supply chains in these
manufacturing lines should be moving out
of china and working with our allies
having the opportunity to relocate these
is something that is going to help us
to not get into a crisis position with
our critical supply chains
most recently there's been international
concern about a chinese tennis star who
accused a former high-ranking government
official of sexual assault she wasn't
heard from for a while after that and
even though she has since turned up safe
skeptics including the women's tennis
association ceo question whether she's
really free senator blackburn and fellow
gop senator tom cotton are calling for a
boycott of the upcoming winter olympics
in beijing i kind of like the way the
women's tennis association the wta has
approached this and good for them
because of feng shui and what she has
endured from the chinese communist party
and the way they disappeared her after
her tweet went up then the wta has said
they will not play tennis
in china
and that's the right approach to take
more companies
and more u.s based entities should take
that same approach
and deny china
the ability to showcase themselves
during these sporting events and these
tournaments
just one other question for you as we
are here in the holiday season um it
seems like it's been kind of a fast year
in a lot of ways
um what would your message be to the
american people especially to anyone
concerned about
the state of the pandemic right now and
the state of the country we still live
in the uh greatest country on the face
of the earth the united states of
america is the beacon of freedom it is a
a country and a nation that has been so
richly blessed and protected there is so
much to be grateful for and to be
thankful for and our prayer during the
holidays should be
that we express that gratitude and that
we remember well
those that have fought for those
freedoms and that we celebrate that and
that we commit
to doing our part to make certain that
we are able to pass that freedom on
to our children and grandchildren
tennessee republican senator marcia
blackburn thanks so much for your time
thank you for allowing me to join you
[Music]
this is david marcus with your fox news
commentary coming up
major league baseball is now in a labor
lockout management's version of a strike
with their collective bargaining
agreement with players expired and talks
ending with no new deal commissioner rob
manfred we feel it's the best strategy
to protect the 2022 season for the
benefit of our
fans we made the mistake of playing
without a collective bargaining
agreement in 1994
and it cost our fans and our clubs
dearly we will not make that same
mistake again players went on strike
during the season in 1994 the world
series was cancelled then the season
started late in 95 once a deal was
reached the sides have worked out
agreements four times since then but the
players union is fighting for change the
players for years have made it clear
that they believe that the economic
system was not working
that
more radical more drastic changes were
necessary jared diamond writes about
sports particularly baseball for the
wall street journal and the owners not
surprisingly believe that the status quo
is going pretty well and we don't need
to make these big changes and that's a
big problem when you have two parties
that
are looking at the landscape and see two
completely different things and that's
why we are where we are where the two
sides are still incredibly far apart
they've been there's been virtually no
movement on the core economic issues and
uh it might be a while before they start
speaking the same language i mean
revenues have really skyrocketed over
the last what 10 15 years i mean and
it's hard to measure the pie the owners
aren't exactly known for being open with
the books that's very true especially
because nowadays so much of ownership
revenue uh is coming from say the real
estate ventures around their ballpark
which
are not counted as baseball revenue but
very clearly are related to their
ownership of baseball teams and we don't
really have a good sense in most cases
of the revenues owners are making what
we do know is that franchise valuations
continue to skyrocket we've seen over
the course of the last cba even a
franchise like the miami marlins
which you know is probably one of the
among the lowest valued teams was sold
for over a billion dollars so if that's
the case imagine how much a team like
the new york yankees or the boston red
sox would be died if they were to go
onto the market the players meanwhile
are still making lots of money and in
some ways especially the star players we
just saw that this week with some of
these giant contracts but
it's not going to every player and that
is really the heart of this issue where
uh the league
believes that this is an issue of
distribution that there's a wealth gap
in baseball and they're willing to sort
of take money from the high-end players
and give it to some of the younger
players the players want a bigger stair
of the pie altogether
and that's where we are
to get a little inside baseball here you
mentioned the wealth gap what's happened
is management's gotten smarter about not
overspending on aging veterans they
realize oh we shouldn't be paying for
what a guy did we should be paying for
what a guy's gonna do
and these younger players haven't gotten
big paydays yet so
what do the players want to happen here
if you get more money to the younger
players that makes the expensive
veterans look less unattractive if you
get my drift
exactly it's an interesting point and i
i think the players and i not i think i
know the players understand
why
owners or rather general managers and
front offices armed with these mountains
and mountains of data analytics
are recognizing that these older players
are maybe not as valuable and there's a
bunch of reasons for that we've seen the
aging curve sort of revert back to
something a little bit more normal in
the post p.e.d
era or at least in the testing era for
for steroids we're not seeing guys that
are 35 36 37 years old put up the
numbers they were in the 90s and early
2000s the players understand that but
their argument
is okay we have a system that for a long
time worked because players were
accepting the fact that they would be
underpaid early in their career in order
to be perhaps overpaid later in their
career that was the trade-off and it
worked very well for everybody except
now
maybe smartly
the front offices have said all right
but we're not going to pay you early in
your career because we don't have to
buy a collectively bargained agreement
and we're also not going to pay you
later in your careers because we don't
want to so the players are saying well
now we're taking it on both ends it has
to be one or the other
so one of the things the players is
pushing for is trying to get players
paid more in line with their performance
early in their careers
but the problem for the players is that
they also don't
want to take away this idea that a star
player can get a 350 million dollar
contract so that's sort of the give and
take that everyone's working with here
how do we get
players paid younger while still
protecting the interest of the
very very very high-end superstar who
has not been negatively impacted at all
by this squeeze on free agents now teams
share national tv contracts they have
their own you know mlb app for streaming
money and some teams though have really
big local cable deals or own their own
you know regional sports network some
just don't though and that's a bubble
overall that could burst as more people
cut cable is that a concern with these
negotiations or is there a plan to get
in on more streaming money team by team
going forward
it's an issue for sure there's a big
disparity like you mentioned in some of
these deals you look at a team like the
dodgers who whose tv deal is just
so exorbitantly high and then you see
some of these teams now that are still
trying to figure out what their future
is going to be especially
in the wake of the sale uh from which
was fox then to disney but then disney
had to sell them ended up now with
sinclair and and you have this valley
network of of rsn's and sort of unclear
what the future of those are going to be
you have these issues of uh streaming
the blackout issues with streaming is a
big one that majoring baseball is very
focused on
so for the owners this is a very big
big deal this is such a huge part of
where their revenue comes from these
days it's not from gates like it used to
be it's from these local and of course
the giant national tv deals uh as well
so it's a big issue it's you know it's
one reason why you're seeing so much
talk about an expanded postseason which
i think is all but certain to be part of
the new cba in some capacity uh because
that's revenue that basically all goes
to the owners they really really want it
and it is a a rare piece of leverage for
the players where they're able to say
we'll give you the expanded playoffs
that you we know you want which you know
realistically is hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars into the owner's
pockets you can argue either way
expanded playoffs for the players you
could say
um okay well it's easier to get to the
playoffs so we don't have to spend as
much on the you know maybe more marginal
aspects of our roster or you could say
geez we've got a shot to get into the
playoffs maybe we should spend a little
more money at the margins
that's the interesting thing about all
of this is that
the owners really want expanded playoffs
the players are not opposed to expanded
class they never had them i would say
where they are of unsure
because what they're trying to figure
out is what is that sweet spot where
does it cross over what is the right
number of teams that inspires
competition as opposed to undermining
did you look at other sports we could
look at say the nba for instance where
16 out of the 30 teams make the playoffs
and in that sport realistically if
you're one of those bottom playoff teams
you have no chance of of advancing you
they go into the first round against the
number one number two seats and get
blown out of the water it's a total
waste of time and there's really no
benefit to making it in fact there's
probably a benefit to not making it for
some of those nba teams baseball
players do not want that but they do
like the idea of a playoff system where
teams are going for it i mean one thing
we've seen in recent years where
baseball started this sort of one game
play in the second wild card uh players
would argue in some ways that had a
negative effect the one game plan
because what happened was team sort of
said well it's a one-game playoff it's a
50-50 crapshoot it's not worth
us you know trading away prospects and
spending money to go for that one game
so they would argue that system hasn't
worked so maybe there's a way to change
it it's just a matter of figuring out on
from their perspective what is it the
owners proposed a 14-team postseason uh
the players have proposed 12 currently
it's 10. we'll see where they end up i
wouldn't be surprised if we end up at
12. jared you don't expect this to get
resolved immediately um there's just no
sense of urgency right now do you think
that a sense of urgency kicks in as we
get
into february and spring training you
know maybe we
lose a week of spring training but i
can't imagine anybody wants this to go
into the regular season
yeah i i've been telling people about
this like if we get to super bowl sunday
and they're still
in nowhere's land like they are now
that's that's a big problem a lockdown
in december and january doesn't really
matter you know these arguments are part
of the process no one's really being
affected
no fan is really being affected there's
tons of other sports out there uh if we
get though to spring you know into
february and there's nothing then they
have a problem but look the thing is
that's also what's gonna start
motivating people right i mean the
owners start losing gate revenue those
cactus and grapefruit the games are not
happening the players of course would
start losing their money
on march 31st when opening day is
supposed to be
they're smart people and i
want to believe do believe
that they recognize that missing part of
the season is not good for anybody it's
a it's bad it'll be really
really bad so hopefully as we get closer
that starts motivating them to make a
deal like you said i don't think we're
going to see anything anytime soon
in fact
this is speculation i'm not saying this
could i've been told but i'd be
surprised if anything really happens in
december
i think we're kind of gonna get a big
lull here and then we get into the
holidays and then new year's and then
they'll say let's come back in january
and hopefully then they sort of get down
to it and are able to figure something
out because like i said right now
they're not really talking to each other
they're sort of just talking over each
other at some point that's going to have
to change and i really view sort of that
first weekend in february as uh that's
when things get serious
well either way i hope to talk to you
again in a couple of months uh and see
where we are jared diamond writes about
sports for the wall street journal
focusing on major league baseball jared
thanks a lot sounds great thanks a lot
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at
guybensonshow.com read and review the
fox news rundown on apple podcasts or
wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
an overdue library book is back on the
shelf at the boise idaho public library
now before you start to wonder why this
is news consider this it had been
checked out for more than a hundred
years
the book new chronicles of rebecca by
kate douglas wigan is the sequel to the
novel rebecca of sunnybrook farm both of
those books were published in the early
1900s the first one in 1903 and the
second in 1907. the folks at the boise
library say that book had been checked
out a total of 15 times before it went
missing from boise's carnegie public
library in 1910
photos shared by the library say it
appears to have been checked out in
1911.
at that time overdue books would have
been fined at a rate of two cents per
day
if you do the math you'll find that at
that amount for 111 years the fine would
have been more than eight hundred
dollars the boise library system did
away with overdue book finds in 2019
and if you're wondering who brought the
book back also are the rest of us a
library spokesperson says the person who
returned that book has not identified
themselves tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
david marcus
what's on your mind as president biden
announces a slew of new covet
restrictions it's worth taking a look
back at the failures of the cast of
bunglers and bumblers he has put in
charge of what we can and cannot do
it is a shameful record that strongly
suggests none of these people should be
in charge of an arby's drive through
much less our pandemic response
dr anthony fauci the self-appointed
emperor god of science taken a lot of
heat these days and for good reason it's
not just his cavalcade of mistakes over
the past two years
but also his refusal to accept any
criticism of himself as even vaguely
legitimate
but honestly the problem is far bigger
than fouchy in fact the entirety of
president joe biden's white house
coveted task force has been an abysmal
disaster and it's time for a change
the task force is led by jeff science
and features cdc director rochelle
wolinski and foutry as the scientific
faces of the operation
let's take a look at the havoc they have
brought
in early may the cdc quietly announced
they would stop tracking breakthrough
cases that did not lead to
hospitalization or death
at the time experts warned this was a
terrible decision why they feared it
would leave scientists blind if a new
variant emerged that is of course
exactly what happened
by august as the delta variant was
surging faulcy would reverse course
telling meet the press we need to do
more testing of the vaccinated in fact
at that point nobody in the task force
or at the white house could answer just
how susceptible vaccinated people were
to the new strain of the virus or how
much they could spread it because they
hadn't bothered to track it now as the
omicron variant looms on the horizon
another abject failure of the biden task
force has become clear
whatever one may say about the excessive
nature of the marathon task force press
conferences of the trump era every
question was answered this task force
instead holds zoom pressers often as
short as 25 minutes with few questions
and even fewer follow-ups the result is
that the citizenry through its news
media has been utterly unable to
effectively interrogate the ivory tower
elite scientists apparently making huge
decisions about our lives had the task
force allowed its feet to be held to the
fire by the press
many of the mistakes could have been
avoided
instead a steady lack of trust has taken
hold americans are needlessly confused
and and have been almost since the
moment biden took the oath of office
transparency has been replaced by shut
up and do as you're told
from the border to afghanistan to the
economy it is clear that biden has no
desire to punish incompetence it is hard
to imagine what if any kind of
disastrous mismanagement could get
anybody in the administration fired but
as regards the task force change is
needed and it is needed today we need
transparency we need competence we need
real press conferences
put simply we need wholesale change in
the scientific leadership of our
pandemic response more than anything we
need a task force that does the research
and tells us the unvarnished truth
not whatever they think will bend our
behavior to their will
until that happens this national
nightmare
will never end i'm david marcus the
author of charade the covet lies that
crushed a nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes